مشاهدينا ان نتوقف قليلا عند التطورات
الخلاف بين قوات الدعم السريع وقياده
الجيش هذه الخلافات طفت الى السطح منذ ان
بدا الحديث عن دمج قوات الدعم السريع في
جيش موحد ففي السادس من يونيو عام 2021
اعلنا حميدتي ان الحديث عن دمج قوات الدعم
السريع في الجيش يمكن ان يفكك البلد تطورت
الخلافات الى ان صراحه الماضي بان اجراءات
البرهان التي حل بموجبها مجلس السياده في
2021 فشلت وان السودان اصبح بحال اسوا في
الخامس من ديسمبر وبتوقيع الاتفاق
الايطالي المؤسس للفتره الانتقاليه عاد
الخلاف بقوه بين الطرفين في مساله دمج
قوات الدعم السريع تاكد ذلك عندما انسحب
ممثل الجيش من ورشه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري هيئه مارس الماضي وقبل ساعات من
جلستها الختاميه لعدم شمول توصياتها ضمن
جدوله زمنيه لعمليه الدمج
في الثاني عشر من الشهر الجاري بدات قوات
الدعم السريع الانتشار في مناطق بالعاصمه
الخرطوم وبعض المدن دون علم قياده الجيش
او تنسيق معها